chick lied Alice cried and I totally
called it you guys let's break down
episode 219 on Sweetwater secrets o-m-g
River babes that was such a good episode
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
the Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 219 chapter 32 prisoners which
was jam-packed with shocking storylines
nobody knew business and the most chic
funeral I had ever seen
yeah which is why I'm wearing this but
now I'm kind of over it so I'm just
gonna toss it okay today I'm bringing
you exclusive interviews from matron a
MEC and Skeet Ulrich talking all about
the phallus relationship revolution Plus
get ready for a seriously sharp list of
hisses and kisses it came from the core
of my bosom but first it's time to recap
the biggest headlines of the week in the
blue and gold breakdown oh did you think
the musical episode was over well think
again because the episode opened with
Cheryl singing a somber tune for their
fallen vixen Mitch
[Music]
and fresh off of the triumphant takedown
of her mother Cheryl Unleashed verbal
whiplash on her newest victim sheriff
Keller your days of failing this town
over and over again are numbered after
some hazing it looks like sheriff Keller
has decided to quit but instead of
bringing in someone new might I suggest
you just let Betty and Jughead take over
the job clearly they're doing a much
better job and than anyone else in town
because bug head went back to the
sisters of quiet Mercy and obtained a
photo of Betty's brother her real
brother that is turns out chick has been
impersonating Charles Smith this whole
time that is your real son not this con
artist there's an intruder
male Caucasian possibly armed certainly
where in my kitchen
are you angry yeah me too luckily
Betty's aggressive side helped ease our
frustrations now to make matters even
more satisfying turns out we were right
all along
Alice revealed to Effie that he really
was the father of her long lost baby
named Charles
unfortunately it looks like we'll never
get to meet the real Charles because
chick killed him
kind of fight I lost control oh that's
the ominous and official return of Betty
once again teamed up with the mysterious
man and offer to relinquish chick aka
the ultimate center over to the black
hood better run chickadee
and it looks like the truth behind the
hood is finally close to being revealed
because Betty is slowly but surely
putting the pieces together mom where's
dad I knew it I knew it I knew it
how it's totally how I'm not quite sure
but I think it's hell don't know that we
know they know we know but wait there's
more now to make matters even worse the
ultraviolent Claire made an obnoxious
return how you been
Ronny yeah Veronica's ex BAE was
hell-bent on revenge so he kidnapped
Archie and demanded a hefty ransom and
when Veronica couldn't pay Nik suggested
a stomach-churning
alternative at bedroom rendezvous while
Archie watched you're a reptile but hell
hath no fury like a Veronica scorned and
while Nick thought that he was about to
get lucky our raven-haired Beauty had
her own idea of revenge which leads us
into our seven seconds in heaven with
Nick passed out on the bedroom floor
barchi reunited with a swoon worthy kiss
and some couples bonding what are we
going to do with him now he's just
sending out the power trip I'm kidding
I don't know Vee I hear the couple who
tortures together stays together
meanwhile Betty and Jughead gave us some
adorable Sherlock Holmes and Watson
vibes and it was so great to see them
teaming up even though it was under some
pretty particularly disturbing
circumstances as for phallus
who else was ugly crying right along
with Alice when she dropped two
bombshells to FP first she revealed that
she carried his child and then was
forced to reveal that their real son had
died he's dead because of me my heart
luckily the Riverdale actors are a-okay
in real life in fact take a look at what
mate genomic and Skeet Ulrich adorably
told me when I press them about Alice
and FPS possible parenting is FP chicks
father
next question doesn't he look like a
combination of the two sure does that's
a layered
that's a layered answer there which
you're gonna start to see in a couple
episodes you'll come to a conclusion
okay I was right about FP being the
father of alice's baby just not that
chick straight up stole Charles's
identity but hey I'm still proud of all
of us for theorizing in the comments
okay and if you're still dying for more
answers head over to ET online and read
my full interview with heart Denton all
about chicks true intentions I'll
include the link below be waiting but
now let's dive straight into this week's
kisses and kisses but I've gotta warn ya
it's a long list this week starting off
the biggest hiss is of course going to
chick for straight-up stealin Charles
Smith's
identity and from making Alice believe
that she inadvertently murdered her own
son and lastly for actually killing him
I hope you get what's coming to you
chick it's your very own Angel of Death
kisses to the black hood aka Hal Cooper
for keeping us in the dark about your
motives also you kind of waddle when you
run sorry not sorry
hisses tunic st. Claire for returning to
Riverdale with a new douche tastic beard
and for torturing Archie and
blackmailing Veronica to try and get her
into bed an extra hiss to the lodges
we're not paying Archie's ransom or even
helping at all hisses - Ethel for
sending those fake letters as the black
hood I was a good since you were the
victim of a particularly vicious hiss
last week I'm gonna ease up on you
slightly and just say this go away girl
you bugs do you know what it means to
clap back Raymond because I do this is
to the fact that Tony was m.i.a from
this episode she's a vixen - and so is
Josie where were they a midgets funeral
was their absence the reason that Cheryl
was particularly prickly in this episode
we need answers oh and on that note
hisses - the fact that we didn't find
out anything about what happened
backstage at the musical why was bang a
midges dressing room what's the deal
with moose don't make
me wait hisses - the fact that Betty
casually lied to Jughead about shad him
with the black hood but I did love that
her lie coincided with our theory that
it's how say your mom no it's my dad and
then I'm sending so many kisses to Betty
for kicking chicks butt to Jughead for
standing by his girl and to F P for
having jugheads best interest at heart
he really is such a great dad kisses to
Veronica for getting her revenge on Nick
st. Claire and for being the only one to
come to Archie's rescue also way to go
girl I love the way you stood up to your
parents this week to help me out of
whatever nefarious schemes you're
cooking up kisses to meet genomic for
her heart-wrenching performance to pp
and to the Riverdale riders because this
episode was jam-packed with twists and
was one of my favorites of this season
congratulations
Ted we're done that's 19 episodes down
and only three more to go now join me
for next week's Sweetwater secrets
preview show of episode 2 2033 shadow of
a doubt for even more exclusive scoop
straight from your favorite Riverdale
stars plus head over to ET online right
now if the link is below
to read my full interview with heart
denton AKA chick to find out if chick is
orally gone for good but first please
give this video a like and then hit the
comments and tell me your top hisses and
kisses of the episode did Nick Sinclair
deserve the bigger punishment and do you
really think how Cooper is the black
hood I do tell me we're babes and until
next time kisses to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]